こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
皆さん
ペットボトルのフタで遊んだことはあるでしょうか？
僕が小6の時
めっちくちゃなんかしょうもないのが好きだったんですよ
牛乳瓶のフタでこう、
メンコみたいな戦い方をしたり
お酒のキャップの部分で
コマにして遊んだりしてたんですけども
それの流れで
ペットボトルのキャップをですね、こうやって
お！今スゲー飛んだ
ってやるやつがすごい流行ってたんですよ
小学校の時にね
こういう敵を見つけてペットボトルのキャップで、こう・・・
倒すと
ちょっぴっと楽しいっていう・・・
っていうゲームが流行ってて
僕はメチャクチャ思ってたんですよ
なんでおもちゃの人は牛乳瓶のフタで戦うメンコをおもちゃ化しなかったのか
なんでおもちゃの人は
お酒の焼酎とか日本酒が入ってるあの瓶の先に出てくるあのコマみたいなやつを商品化しなかったのか
なんで！なんで！ペットボトルのフタで
この、スピード凄い出て戦わせるのがおもちゃ化されなかったのか
ずっと疑問に思ってここ23年間生きてきた所存でございますが
今回なんと
あの普通に電気屋さん行ってガチャガチャコーナー
僕いつも見るんですけど
そこ見てたら
わ！
これじゃん
って思うやつがありました
こちらです
5つ買って来ました
色がみんなバラバラだな
ちょっと一個開けてみましょう
ボトルキャップバトラー
うーん
いい名前だ
嫌いじゃない名前のセンスだ
スカイブルー
×
ライトイエロー
3タイプ
全く意味がわかりません
色々パーツが入ってるみたいなんですよね
うわ、なんか作り方が書いてある
なんかコツとかも書いてあります
なんかペットボトルのフタでなんか戦えるみたいなことを書いてありました
いやぁもうねぇ、見た瞬間僕は完璧に来たと思って買っちゃいました５つ
ガチャガチャの中見たら結構減ってたんで
で１００円で、
で、割となんかみんな遊んでんじゃないかなとか思っちゃって
ちょっとびっくりしちゃいました。これちょっと開けてみましょう。
わ、なになに？これ、全く分からん。
3種類あるんですけど、これは多分6点留め式パーツでございます。
すげー、いろいろあるんだな。
これで勢いよく引っ張ったら回転するらしいです
ほんとに？
おおおおー！こういう感じで回るらしいですね。
なるほど、なるほど
なるほど、わからん。
こっとーじゃなくてこうなんだね。
なるほど、なるほど、なるほど、そういうことか。
思ってたのと全然ちがーう。なんだこれは。
これはただのコマじゃないか！
ペットボトルではない、ただのコマだ！
まあ、いいや！
さっ飛ばしたウィルキンソン炭酸のキャップとかをつけられるというわけですな。
あ、こうか、こうだな
これでもう完璧です。
これだけじゃなくて、ここからカスタマイズできるみたいです。
おおーー
こういう感じに進化しました。
ペットボトルのキャップがここまで進化する
思ってたのと全然違う
で、これをさっきのシューターに乗せて
おおー
おお、でもスゲーな、ちゃんと
回転するんだな。
これおもしろいのかな
ひとまずこれ開けましょう、4つ開けます。
はい、というわけで全部出ました。
結構パーツがバラバラで、
ココも違うし、シューターも違うし
武器の部分も全部違ってます。
りょう君？ちょっと君来て
いくよ、いくよ、いくよ、いくよ！
正しい反応
なんやかんやハマる2人
（後輩）おおー
（後輩）楽しい
ほんとに？
えー、ちょっと今から後輩と最強のこれを作ってお互い勝負させます。
（後輩）え、なんだ、なに？
はじめのボトルキャップ
後輩のボトルキャップ
これだと絶対勝てないおもすぎるから
あ、これは？
これならなんか
おー！これ強いな多分
はい、というわけでできました。
僕のやつはコレね、
こちら、トゲトゲしさを追求したこの手裏剣型。
（後輩）これが僕のです。
（後輩）日本の心「お～いお茶」で。
戦ってみましょう。
なんか、ぽい、ぽい、ぽい。ほら。
うまく息を吹きかけてアタック
息吹きかけていいんだね。
一発勝負でキメようぜ。
3.2.1..Go Shoot!
（はじめ）おし！ （後輩）あ、あ、やばい
同点か、同点だな。
3.2.1..Go Shoot!
よっしゃー
アアッ！
すごい・・・痛い・・・